[Música]
en esa foto esa foto la tomaron en la
antártida en enero de este año en una
expedición en la que estuvimos 80
líderes científicas que trabajan en
cambio climático en el mundo de cerca de
30 países pero si yo les hubiera
mostrado esa foto hace 100 años ustedes
me han dicho que esa foto era imposible
que era un montaje fake news porque hace
100 años las mujeres simplemente no iban
a la antártida las mujeres no hizo no
hicieron parte de esas grandes
expediciones que llevaron a shackleton y
otros expedición arios a lograr a
encontrar lugares recónditos del polo
sur
de hecho hay una frase famosa de un
piloto británico que dice es que hay
cosas que las mujeres simplemente no
hacen no llegan a ser papás no llegan a
ser presidentes y no van a la antártida
afortunadamente javi darlington no
estaba en lo cierto hoy en día hay más
de 20 mujeres que son cabeza de estado
en el mundo entonces si llegan a ser
presidentes y la foto que ya les había
mostrado también demuestra que las
mujeres también vamos a la antártida
pero en 100 años pasan muchísimas cosas
y entre otras en estos últimos 100 años
venimos emitiendo millones de toneladas
de carbono a la atmósfera porque pues
básicamente nuestro desarrollo ha hecho
que quememos combustibles fósiles de
forma acelerada y estos combustibles
fósiles liberan carbono que se va
acumulando en la atmósfera generando un
efecto invernadero que está calentando
al planeta cada vez más y la
consecuencia más visible es una
alteración total del sistema climático
global y por eso me quiero devolver a la
antártida porque la antártida es un
lugar muy particular es un lugar que
está sintiendo de manera evidente los
efectos devastadores del cambio
climático
y es una lástima y es muy doloroso en
realidad porque cuando uno llega a la
antártida es como estar en otro planeta
es un lugar hermoso lleno de montañas
gigantes de más de 4.900 metros de
altura con capas de hielo que abarcan
hasta 4 km de hecho en la antártida está
congelada más del 70% del agua dulce del
mundo y esta cifra cobra aún más
relevancia cuando yo les digo que
solamente del agua que existe en el
planeta solamente el 3% es dulce
entonces este continente de hielo es
nuestra reserva de agua
supuestamente la antártida debería
duplicar su tamaño en el invierno en el
verano perdón
pero desafortunadamente con el cambio
climático este lugar tan importante se
está derritiendo rápidamente se está
disminuyendo el hielo marino y eso está
teniendo efectos devastadores en las
especies por ejemplo uno de los
principales perdedores son los pingüinos
adelia especies antárticas cuyas
poblaciones están disminuyendo a un paso
acelerado pero no es el único lugar en
el mundo que está viviendo estas graves
consecuencias de hecho al otro lado del
planeta en el polo norte también estamos
viviendo algo muy similar el año pasado
en febrero se registraron temperaturas
28 grados por encima de lo normal en el
polo norte
y esto tampoco es raro si tenemos en
cuenta
desde 2001 básicamente hemos tenido los
18 años más calientes de la historia
estamos rompiendo récords cada año es
más caliente que la anterior y cada año
normalizamos esto de hecho los últimos
cuatro años además han sido los más
calientes y esto está generando efectos
devastadores en el mundo entero
desde huracanes quién se acuerda esa
serie de huracanes que trajo a irma
después amarilla hace dos años donde las
pequeñas islas del caribe sufrieron
efectos devastadores inundaciones pero
también estamos viendo exceso de lluvia
bombas de agua en otras partes del mundo
y del exceso de agua de la abundancia
pasamos muy rápidamente a las olas de
calor que están matando también a miles
de personas en el mundo
a las sequías sequías sin precedentes
a los incendios forestales ejemplo
california ha vivido los peores
incendios forestales de nuestra historia
pero esto no es lejano de hecho ahorita
este año colombia estamos en sequía y
esta es una foto del instituto sinchi en
este momento mientras nosotros hablamos
acá hay más de 3000 incendios que están
ocurriendo en la amazonía colombiana
bueno esto es solamente aunque el
planeta se ha calentado un grado en
relación con la temperatura pre
industrial ahora yo les quiero preguntar
a ustedes qué pasaría si nos calentamos
otro grado más como sería el mundo
y yo los quiero llevar y transportar a
esa pesadilla en la que no queremos
vivir por ejemplo en el caso de colombia
los páramos que es ese ecosistema tan
valioso que tenemos acá que nos provee
de agua al 70% de los colombianos
desaparecería no sería viable en un
mundo de dos grados otro gran perdedor
del cual dependemos también para nuestra
seguridad alimentaria y para el turismo
los corales los corales no son viables
en un mundo de dos grados y qué pasaría
con ciudades por ejemplo como cartagena
cartagena estaría en gran parte cubierta
por el agua porque el aumento en el
nivel del mar llegaría a más de medio
metro
y qué pasa con enfermedades como el cica
y el chikungunya transmitida por
vectores podrían inclusive llegar hasta
bogotá
entonces no creo que ese sea el mundo
que nos merecemos ninguno de nosotros ni
nuestros hijos pero entonces yo les
tengo acá una muy buena noticia levante
la mano quien tiene entre 20 y 60 años
en este salón
todos eso bueno les tengo una muy buena
noticia es algo que tenemos que estar
muy felices porque todavía hay esperanza
y es que el año pasado el panel
intergubernamental de cambio climático
que agrupa a miles de científicos a lo
largo del mundo sacó un informe
revelador donde nos dijeron tienen
literalmente 12 años ni uno más para
revertir esta situación para garantizar
que no lleguemos a ese mundo horrible de
dos grados de aumento de la temperatura
global promedio entonces ustedes y yo
nosotros somos la última generación que
le puede hacer frente al cambio
climático y 12 años ustedes van a decir
eso en presiones muchos son tres
gobiernos presidenciales de colombia
no es mucho y la verdad que es una carga
muy pesada no solamente tener 12 años
para cambiar este panorama y lo es y yo
la verdad no les voy a quitar esa carga
la carga se queda lo que sí voy a hacer
es darles una herramienta que yo creo
que nos puede ayudar a que esa carga la
llevemos juntos de una mejor forma
les voy a dar un regalo que nos va a
permitir hacerle frente al cambio
climático y salir victoriosos en estos
12 años esto es el optimismo testarudo
soy una optimista testaruda y esto es
una lección de vida porque tenemos que
pensar que si se puede que si es posible
revertir el cambio climático esto no nos
va a asegurar el éxito debo decir pero
si el buen comienzo o dígame usted es
que gran empresa en la historia de la
humanidad que gran victoria
ha empezado con pesimismo ninguno
entonces el optimismo testarudo es una
lección para decir definir que si se
puede que esto es un reto al que si no
le podemos medir y si podemos lograrlo
en 12 años y ahora los quiero remontar a
1962 está jon efe que ni en un estadio
en texas rodeado de miles de personas
diciendo lo siguiente decidimos llegar a
la luna en esta década no porque fuera
fácil sino porque es difícil pero es el
reto que nos propusimos que no podemos
posponer y es el reto que vamos a ganar
bueno qué pasó siete años después siete
años después estaba neil amstrong
pisando la luna muchos de ustedes quizá
lo presenciaron marcó la historia de la
humanidad la misión apolo duró 12 años
en los que alinearon a todo el mundo
para llegar a la luna que era algo que
parecía imposible será tan imposible
hacerle frente al cambio climático tan
imposible como llegar a la luna
yo creo que
john f.kennedy era un optimista
testarudo pero les voy a presentar a
otra gran optimista testaruda estás
christiana figueres que es una de las
mujeres que fue con nosotros a la
antártida y christiana figueres asumió
las negociaciones de cambio climático en
2009 cuando todo el mundo pensaba que
eso era imposible
que nunca jamás en el mundo se iba a
lograr un acuerdo global de cambio
climático la prensa estaba en contra los
países no se ponían de acuerdo y
adivinen qué pasó seis años después en
parís se adoptó un acuerdo global de
cambio climático que pone de acuerdo a
todos los países del mundo a que nos
vamos a encaminar a un mundo de menos de
2 grados de aumento de la temperatura
global promedio y cuando estábamos en la
antártida oyendo sus grandes historias
le preguntamos a cristian a bueno y
usted cómo hizo eso eso parecía
imposible que fue
nos dijo todos los días me levanté a
trabajar con optimismo testarudo de que
yo iba a lograr este gran reto porque si
no era yo quien si no era ahora cuando y
la verdad es que esas palabras de
cristiana para mí fueron supremamente
inspiradoras optimismo testarudo y yo
les quiero traducir lo que significa
optimismo testarudo para mí lo primero
es que no nos podemos dar por vencidos y
lo que nos digan que es imposible lo
volvemos posible y acá está la imagen de
creta una adolescente sueca que está
haciendo huelga todos los viernes no
está yendo al colegio hasta que el
gobierno no aumente su ambición para
hacerle frente al cambio climático y ha
creado un movimiento de estudiantes a
nivel global nosotros no aceptamos lo
que nos dicen que es posible exigimos
más como consumidores le exigimos más a
nuestras marcas como trabajadores más a
las empresas como electores más a
nuestros gobernantes lo segundo
es que cada día vamos por más esto es un
camino son 12 años no significa que
mañana vamos a ser perfectos pero que en
este camino hacer cada vez más
sostenibles
todos los días nos exigimos un poquito
más y no estamos contentos con los
resultados
y lo tercero y quizá lo más importante
es que acá la unión hace la fuerza
porque yo puedo estar acá sola
insignificante dándoles un discurso sola
quizá no llego muy lejos pero juntos
todos juntos todos somos invencibles
juntos no nos para nadie juntos le
hacemos frente al cambio climático y a
cualquier otro reto que nos pongan en el
camino
y bueno no va a ser fácil les digo estos
11 años no van a ser fácil va a ser
quizás tan difícil es como pasar por el
pasaje de drake de regreso de la
antártida nos tocaron todos los días
pasando por el pasaje de drake con olas
de 12 metros fue duro estuvimos bastante
horas
bastantes horas en cama la mayoría nos
enfermamos pero trabajamos juntas las 80
mujeres y luego de los dos días llegamos
al canal del vigo donde nos recibieron
aguas calmas un sol resplandeciente y yo
creo que estos 12 años que se nos vienen
encima van a ser un poco similares al
pasaje de drake pero sé que si
trabajamos juntos con optimismo
testarudo vamos a llegar a un puerto
seguro y la buena noticia es que en este
caso literalmente todos estamos en el
mismo barco solamente tenemos un planeta
no no tenemos plan b hasta ahora no nos
podemos bajar entonces estamos unidos y
la verdad que para mí
cuando estaba en la antártida una de las
cosas
realmente me transformaron fue darme
cuenta que yo no estaba sola que hay
muchísimas optimistas de estar dudas en
el mundo como yo y se las quiero
presentar algunas no se las puedo
presentar a todas pero por ejemplo estas
calling
ella es una sudafricana que decidió
montar una reserva en mozambique a pesar
de que todo el mundo le dijo que estaba
loca y todos los días lucha contra la
caza ilegal de leones y elefantes
o por ejemplo divino a una china que
todo el mundo le decía es imposible que
el gobierno abra las puertas y logró
sentar al gobierno chino con ongs hablar
sobre cambio climático no se rindió o
qué tal natal y natalie es una joven
brasilera que trabajó muchos años en
política de cambio climático después se
cansó de la forma como se hacía política
en su país montó un movimiento que puso
a cerca de 20 nuevos líderes en el
congreso brasilero y hoy es la
superintendente del estado de paraná o
qué tal marina marina inició su carrera
como una líder ambiental a los 9 años y
hoy en día tiene una fundación en
argentina que ha capacitado a cientos de
jóvenes líderes en el mundo inspirando
los o melania melania es una oceanógrafa
costarricense que de hecho le dijeron en
algún momento de su vida que ella no iba
a ser capaz que no iba a poder hacer su
doctorado y no solamente hizo su
doctorado sino que además se ha dedicado
a estudiar la polución auditiva en el
ártico y los efectos que esto tiene con
las
si está trabajando desde la diplomacia
internacional para salvar a los océanos
optará que trabajó muchos años en
política de cambio climático en las
negociaciones y hoy lidera un movimiento
para liberar del plástico de un solo uso
a su ciudad natal 15 en irlanda
pero esas no son las únicas la verdad es
que yo me fui en una expedición a la
antártida con 80 optimistas de estar
dudas 80 optimistas de verdad que están
dispuestas a dar esta batalla y no son
solo ellas la verdad que el optimismo
testarudo es contagioso y que una vez
todos nos contagiamos somos capaz de
hacer cualquier cosa inclusive hacerle
frente al cambio climático no nos
rendimos hacemos que lo imposible sea
posible no aceptamos un no como
respuesta y adicionalmente no se les
olvide esta gran frase y es que después
del último no
siempre viene un sí
de éstas y de ese se vende el futuro del
planeta yo
carolina garcía soy una optimista
testaruda ustedes que quieren ser
[Música]